hallo leute ich es wieder eure bio wanne
und willkommen zu einem neuen video
heute werden bio süßigkeiten und snacks
getestet denn ich war bei bio markt
natürlich nur mit jute beutel denn's
biomarkt sehr beliebter bioladen in
berlin ich weiß gar nicht ob es den auch
außerhalb von berlin gibt also ich denke
mal schon weil das ist sieht schon so
aus wie zu die kette also ich kann mir
gut vorstellen also schreibt gerne mal
ob es in eurer stadt einen denn's
biomarkt gibt die dachte wenn ich mich
durch nanu nana und ikea durchgefüttert
habt ist es mal an der zeit etwas bio
fairtrade halbwegs gesundes zu probieren
ich bin jetzt nicht jemand der
regelmäßig in biomärkten einkauf ich
habe schon welche von innen gesehen aber
die preise schrecken mich dann doch
öfter mal ab bin ehrlich mit euch so
wurde ich nicht erzogen das ist mir auch
zu teuer manchmal und wenn wir noch
gerade beim thema sind schreibt mal geht
ihr gerne in den biomarkt und wenn ja
welche produkte sind eure westhoff
biomarkt produkte einfach alles
mitgenommen was interessant aus sound
ich würde sagen lasst uns testen
ich habe auf diesen karten mit meinem
leben aufgepasst jetzt sehr einfach weg
oder das gehen soll hätte
[Musik]
hier ist produkt nummer eins ist das
porto überraschungsei für zwei euro 25
habe übrigens insgesamt 37 euro
ausgegeben
mein bio heißt ja auch nicht immer
veganern so da ist auf jeden fall freue
mich der ganze scheiß drin aber keine
milch creme von der schokolade bekommt
man schon all die weihnachtsmann vibes
aber sie ist auch ein lecker also jeder
auf jeden fall klar aber sind wir mal
ehrlich bei diesen überraschungsei jubt
und sich der geschmack sondern die
überraschung toll ist dies ein super
klasse war ich kann nicht ganz sagen was
es ist ein anhänger aber kommen also das
schreit ihr bio
das ist halt einfach so eine holzfiguren
probieren wir mal die bio antwort
aufbauen sagt peter kokosnuss haben
diese jetzt auch vegan und sehen ganz
gut aus
oh mein gott das ist wirklich die
antwort aufbauen team diesen lecker an
drei haken bekommt man für 1 eur 27 was
ich besonders gut finde ist das war mir
immer so ein ticken zu süß ist die dafür
berlin ex profi ihn balls marx mecking
wenn dein immunsystem unterstützung
braucht glaubt nie an solche sachen
unsere protec boards mit erdbeere
hibiskus und michael pilz sind genau das
richtige für dich mit natürlichem
vitamin c aus acerola kirsche es war
irgendwie witzig sind so roth so sehen
und schmecken tun du mir hat das
entwickelt hat dann gesagt ja zu
verkaufen ist weiß wie man keinen zu
können so das verwendete klar schmeckt
das nicht wie eine süßigkeit aber ich
brauche etwas was mir gute laune macht
felix reis snacks wäre laut werde nur
mit fruchtsaft gesüßt also sowas wie
noch nie probiert
also sorry keeper packung zeigt auf
jeden fall nicht wie das produkt aus sie
trotzdem probieren bis jetzt schmecken
wie ganz normale reiswaffeln reis waffe
mit ein bisschen sauer um drauf also ich
finde schon die hätten das hat voll
machen können damit auf einer seite ist
auch so ein bisschen also diese
verpackung zeigt was ganz anderes team
fährt gleich nach köln nicht im gleichen
reisepaket damit machen und mein kind
dieses super susan rice nec dass ein
bisschen geschmack daran ein bisschen
saft hat man nicht so ein schlechtes
gewissen wenn es das nicht aber ich hab
sie mir gesteht ich habe sie mir gerne
vorgestellt wie kriegt man übrigens
felix 97 cent
ja
wenn ich ein kind habe und ihn ein snack
kaufen möchte perfekt aber für mich
persönlich nein danke da gibt es
kribbelt cheeseburger als unser nächstes
produkt ist so das woran ich denke wenn
ich an bio süßigkeiten denke hafer tier
kekse ohne zucker süßungsmittel bio in
ried toll wie die aus unserem video
süßigkeiten oder zucker gelernt haben
es ist trotzdem eine art von zucker lag
ja was soll ich sagen in dieser csis
brauchen nicht kaufen auch nicht für
zwei euro und 93 schmeckt halt als ob
man sich ein löffel haferflocken schiebt
nächste ich glaube ich hatte die schon
mal ich bin mir aber nicht ganz sicher
ob your vegetable chips chips aber nicht
nur von kartoffelchips
ich glaub kurze zeit war das auch echt
trend dass ein bisschen aus wie sie
verwelkte blumen wir eine rote beete
team
karotte hmm
parship ist diese wurzel wie heißt sie
nochmal pastinaken man kriegt auf jeden
fall nicht diese chips satisfaction bei
kartoffelchips aber bei sweet potatoe
schon zwei euro 44 03 von soja und milch
ohne raffinierten zucker hergestellt
unter 45 grad weiße tafel mit pistazien
und salzburg knapp drei euro
[Musik]
okay wir nehmen uns mal ein ich meine
der gedanke ist gut aber die umsetzung
ist halt wenn man schokolade ist dann
möchte man dieses satisfaction haben
wenn man ein stück in mund nimmt man
denkt und die ist er so nicht so
verstehen was ich meine
nächstes produkt hier einmal auf eine
schokolade die mir schon sehr oft von
veganern empfohlen wurde wego also die
ist vegan löwen frühjahr war rohrzucker
ist und mit hasen hoch wo ich bin
gespannt wie sie gut aus
das ist allerdings mehr gute schokolade
[Musik]
oh mein gott leute hens da und ich habe
schon viel veganisch collage probiert
diese vegane schokolade ist der absolute
hit
lecker die platte gekostet ich glaube
195 aber für den geschmack muss ich
schon sagen da bin ich bereit ist zu
zahlen auf jeden fall bio werden cool
bitter enttäuscht mich nicht her doch
auf jeden fall die sie in hübsch aus
dort hatten mir wäre sinnvoll mit
heidelbeeren und heidelbeeren lila
hamlin scharf bitter
[Musik]
es ist von lecker wenn man hat doch
einerseits die schokolade oder noch die
säure von den früchten dann so einen
quatsch weil die früchte
gefriergetrocknet sind tische lag hier
die landkarten bio beeren seht für 146 g
1 nächstes haben wir bio bärchen kinder
märchen sirup trotz super gelantine
säuerungsmittel also die sind nicht die
sind nicht vegan das sind cola flächen
aber sie sind bio mit bio gelatine
standard wer das als kind auch gemacht
also sieht aus wie normale colaflasche
wie man sie von dieser anderen großen
bekannten marke kennt lecker schmeckt
ich kann ich noch ein erstes schon
soviel wieder gegessen werden schon
bounty aber wie schmeckt wohl bio
raffaello wunderbar zum verschenken
schokokugeln 2025 nicht vegan aber bio
heißt ja nicht immer gleich gedacht
es hat eine weiße creme das ist ein
positiver pluspunkt aber es ist nicht
ansatzweise mit raffaello zu vergleichen
müsste eigentlich vor dem rapid selbst
machen es ist nicht täglich aber nicht
super 8 ich hole mal ganz schnell eine
sache die in die tiefkühltruhe musste
zitrone cooler und exotik zwei euro 13
naja ich auch gesagt okay ich bin so
einen roten erneut gefallen den moment
denkt sieht es schmeckt viel frucht
tiger besser als diese normalen wasser
als die banken gut die normalen kosten
auch irgendwo es beim euro aber
[Musik]
von intensiv die sind richtig gut alles
natürlich bio agaven dicksaft und
rohrzucker gesüßt unser letztes produkt
sehe ich auch immer beiträge an der
kasse und zwar sind es diese bio
sie haben erst mal hier eine haft
verpackung aus dem regenwald wenn die
biologisch abbaubar wie blätter es ist
ja stimmt mein kaugummis ist es ja sonst
so dass wir nicht gut abbaubar sind also
man hat hier so eine tafel so und davon
kann man sich so ein quadrat ab machen
und ich hatte die schon mal mit ihrem
sohn guten geschmack von mir befriedigt
mich diese konsistenz zuerst hat man das
gefühl dass account zu können also es
sich auflöst und haben es langsam zum
kaugummi
mein fazit zu den ganzen produkt ist ein
bisschen gemüt ich finde man kann
richtig gute produkte finden und ich
würde aber jetzt auch nicht sagen dass
alle sogar ein bioladen philipp schmeckt
super lecker und das mega geil ich
glaube wenn es um produkte bio laden
geht sollte man viel auf erfahrungen von
freunden zum beispiel hören oder sich
ein bisschen selber durch probieren auch
wenn das durch probieren in diesem fall
sehr teuer ist macht aber absolut nichts
weiter ab und zu mal in den bioladen
geht um sich produkte zu kaufen das
war's mit meinem video ich habe euch
jetzt gefallen wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder und bis dann
also bio